on this episode the a team joins me
sorry in the end Iraq
this is
ask Gary B hey Rudy this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 186 on
the askgaryvee show where my office I'm
focused I'm gonna go tight today
sneaking this in because I feel like I
haven't done the show in a little bit
Britt good to see you
I like this the sneaker pants matching
thing is pretty cool and won't actually
hat you really you think about these we
think about these things yeah I do not I
fly kicks on today no we think those Pat
my trips though but yeah all right let's
do it
miss you guys are real quick I wasn't
interrupting Seth I'm a bad like it's
not that I'm trying to interrupt Seth
it's my interview style which is not
good by all standards by PR or standard
interview practices but I like it and
I've got a lot of intriguing emails that
are that are countercultural it is what
it is I you know it's how I interview I
get destroyed for it during Wine Library
TV and and maybe it's just something I'm
not that good at though I like what it
brings out it brings out a different
thing if you want to get the commodity
answers and the same old spiel you can
read that and watch that on YouTube and
see it every day it creates a different
energy I understand that it can be
combative at times and no question on
paper level one looks like interruption
cuz it is it is it's my feel so I love
Seth and and that's that so cool first
question
Jimmy asks who owns our usernames us or
the app Facebook Twitter Instagram what
happens if the app came around today and
said we are now charging for your
username would you pay to keep it I
don't think it matters Bret
who asked that Jimmy Jimmy I don't think
it matters like what are they gonna
charge like if if a hook comm came out
and it was the next big thing and I want
to be on it or anchor or if if snapchat
even came around and said look we were
out and
we own all the names and if you want
Gary Vee because you're one of the
people that we've deemed of the 50,000
people that has a user name that's
valuable to them that we're gonna charge
you 100 bucks a year for it you know I
actually don't think it matters meaning
what I pay it sure would a lot of you
payant know would it hold back the app
from winning maybe I don't think any app
would ever take the chance to not become
a big platform because a lot of people
wouldn't sign up for it because those
people were upset that somebody was
charging for the name and so I think
from a PR standpoint and a branding and
positioning standpoint most apps won't
go there if they do if they have the
best product in the world you'll pay for
it
nobody's nope what would I pay
retroactively Lee um probably yeah
probably and I wouldn't give a crap
about it
like you know what are they gonna charge
they can't charge enough you know what I
mean and they're not the Internet
they're not going to meaning like every
one of them is too smart and is too big
of a business to sit there and say okay
like why would they charge Facebook
makes a billion dollars a quarter you
think they want to take the
vulnerability to make an extra fifty
million dollars top-line revenue I mean
listen Jimmy and I'm not razzing on you
there's just sometimes not a good
understanding of big macro business
behaviors like let's just break it down
you think Facebook's that how much
revenue do you think Facebook's were
able to make on charging for names like
what's the most you think somebody can
what's the most even they can charge a
human forget about Pepsi for the name
for a year and like get it want to do it
yeah 20 bucks what a month or overall
like let's let's start over let's let's
start over I pay 500 bucks per year and
I'm a big [ __ ] like deal in the
scheme of things I'm in the top 10% or
1% I don't know of humans with fan bases
right like there's no money in it so
like like the problem that a lot of
people do is they think about it too
much of a micro level there's no money
in it so level up the thinking Jimmy and
crew like cool yes but it'll never
happen because it would break it the
vulnerability is so much greater than
the top-line
revenue when we're making revenue in
other areas so I mean theoretically yes
no it doesn't matter that's my mom I
mean the question matters you mean I
appreciate it I think it's a good
opportunity for me to lessen up for the
masses of like you've got to understand
the reason I'm a good salesman is I
understand what person wants and then I
reverse-engineer it right Facebook wants
money it's a business that money is not
more valuable than the vulnerability
that they put all their other monies to
I'm spending more money on a Facebook ad
today then Facebook could charge me for
the year for the name so why would they
create a vulnerability of me getting
emotional that they pulled the rug from
underneath me and left a bad platform
right it was kind of thinking cool video
question oh yeah yes you said you want a
cool backgrounds Gary so how's this
Brandon Copeland here with beautiful st.
John's Newfoundland and Labrador Canada
behind me have a question from marketing
professional services and professional
services firms if you're trying to
establish legal firm real estate sales
team a management consulting practice
you better suited marketing your brand
and your new company or are you better
suited focusing on the people with the
skills that are providing value to your
clients your market the firm or the
person thanks for your thoughts the
answer is it comes down to you as the
head of that organization to make that
decision on what you're better at if you
if you market the people you have a
vulnerability that the person has the
equity and they can leave right like
this is not the NBA where they're locked
in these contracts they have nowhere to
go you can go that person then can go
and start their own firm and you don't
get any of the economics and that's why
people don't promote the people
underneath them quite a bit I think it's
a mistake because if you show that
you're an organization that promotes
people the next group of people want to
come in and most people aren't risk
adverse enough like the risk tolerance
is so low they don't want to start doing
business they just like to be a top
earner within your organization but I
think you do both you know like I
promote Brandon and Ian when he was at
Wine Library and other people at Wine
Library like more and more people now
that I feel like we've got a grasp what
we do are going out and speaking at
immense as executives for vaynermedia
but I also you also promote the
companies themselves so the answer is
both but I think it's about
self-awareness as an operator if you
think you're better at marketing people
than you are
are getting a logo in an organization
you should spend more of your time on
that if you think you're better at doing
it around a logo or a name than people
because it's awkward to you then you do
that but trying and mixing the two I
think makes a ton of sense Josh asks is
Twitter making a comeback with the
recent addition of gifs I mean I think
that's a narrow question I think I think
Twitter is potentially making a comeback
because they have a new CEO which gives
it a new direction and not that I'm mad
at dick or ever the people that have run
it in the past I think it's just any
time you have a new CEO if one deems
something not working that it's got the
potential to work right I think the the
gifts I'm not letting that go and many
other things extending the character
limit making the feed act differently
these are all debates and actions that
we've seen from Twitter in the last 60
days that are promising because it shows
maneuvering with the product which I
think has been the vulnerability with
the business and so I don't I don't
think just with it
definitely not as a proxy to what's
going on overall at Twitter I think
potentially videos hey Gary Vaynerchuk
jld here and I have a question for you
about snapchat because of you I've been
snapping my face off and loving every
second of it d-roc at John Lee Dumas and
I would love for you to share with us
how do we grow our snapchat followers
you've answered this question before I
haven't loved any of your answers if you
could go deep let's break it down
we're vaynernation how do we grow our
snapchat paul jld wants to grow his base
jld excited I think I'm actually going
on your podcast today which you'll
probably are as the book comes out
that's later my day jelly listen I'm
sorry that I'm not giving you a good
answer the answer is you have to use
every other channel it's using every
other channel and it's hacking you're
doing it right now you threw up your
snap code because you're hoping a bunch
of people in the vaynernation stop it
take a picture of it and add you as a
friend you're doing exactly the right
thing which is you've got to use other
people's platforms and other you know I
collaborating like literally emailing
everybody that you know or messaging
them on Instagram
if they big instagrams assuming that
that that means they have some sort of
community on snapchat and saying hey how
do I take over your channel how do I
give me a shout-out I mean it's
literally endorsements on other people's
snapchat or you I mean listen man make
your podcast over the next six seven
weeks pounding snapchat interview people
about snapchat interview snapchat
executives make your world about
snapchat I've won because I branded
you're looking for a tactic you're
looking for a sales tactic write a
transaction oh go do this buy this
search term do the right like you're
looking for that you're looking for
maybe you should buy the longtail term
on Google as a google adword that says
who should I follow on snapchat and then
maybe you're the first result that you
paid for it's me follow me right that
will work probably cost a buck or two
per follower and that might work but I'm
doing it in marketing and branding by
being about it bout it right by being
about it and by talking about it and by
being out there people are picking up on
that behavior they're writing about me
being in there and yes I sit at a high
level in marketing but there's a lot of
people DJ Khaled wasn't he was a DJ he
went all about it now people give them
exposure right now because there's no
functionality within snapchat to growth
a core pay for ad spend or any other
functionality to build your user base
you have to win on marketing not on
sales jld there's too many people in
2016 that have become internet marketers
and it's all about arbitrage Facebook
ads Pinterest ads Google AdWords
affiliate marketing email marketing
landing page optimization it's all about
tactics it's not about marketing and
religion reason I've done so well on
snapchat is I'm a marketer right I built
Wine Library on marketing not just
transactional couponing and Google
Adwords I've built myself in marketing
coming I built myself in marketing by
building my brand and that's trickled
down it's not just transactional I sell
a lot more books than a lot of people
because it's not the tactics it's the
overall brand it's really the thesis of
jabs our jab right hook those jabs are
branding I'm bringing value and so
there's tactics like you just did jld
but there's also branding and you have a
platform you have a successful podcast
make your content about that and then
there's a lot of tactics like I
mentioned earlier in this rant as I wove
some tactics in there for you but you've
got to level up you're thinking bro I'm
not kidding you know you're gonna rise
I'm gonna rise right back you got to
think marketing versus you know you're
more than welcome to go out and do guest
blog posts on a ton of business sites
about why you think snapchats important
and now you show up in a lot of
distributed places with a call to action
to o-p-s by the way follow me on
snapchat so there's a lot you know you
may not like the answers because you may
not want to do them or you might not
like this answer because marketing is a
lot harder than a growth hack or an
execution it doesn't take away from the
fact that it's the answer the reason so
many people are asking me how to build a
base is because it's not easy because
it's branding and marketing not sales
and transactional I'm excited right now
because that was actually a very
important answer to a lot of questions
that have going on for a long time too
many people here are playing checkers
when the game is really chess branding
and marketing is different than
transactional affiliate it's math versus
branding it's quant Bursa squall
snapchat isn't branding in qua world and
that's just too hard for most of you I'm
gonna end the show right there cuz I
gotta go I know you got others so Ted
show I snuck it in three is better than
zero Stefan thank you question of the
day that last rant expand on that I want
to get into you know to the weekend I
got a couple of errands I have to run so
I have a few minutes to run away from
family to jump in and engage with you
guys around it it's very very very
important I'd like your I'd like your
thoughts on that answer
I'd like your take on that I'd like your
stories about when you did branding or
when you've done you know quanta philia
tour or growth hacking or transactional
you know tactics versus religion I'd
like you to expand on your personal
journey around that last question
because that was super interesting to me
you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them